what are a lot of YouTubers getting
wrong about the MacBook Air M2 when
they're reviewing it well let me ask you
a question when you look at let's say a
Toyota Prius car review do you see this
being put on a Formula One Track do you
see it being raced against a Formula One
car or a Lamborghini or a Porsche or a
Ferrari no you don't why because the car
was never designed to be that kind of
car so then why are so many YouTubers
out there trying to make a MacBook Air
M2 a pro machine and handle Pro types of
content when it was never designed to be
that I get why they're doing it it's
clicks it's engagement it's viewership
this is how YouTubers make money is the
more people to watch the videos the more
money they make from advertising Etc et
cetera et cetera I understand that but
what happens is is that the average
consumer who doesn't understand the
context and how these reviews are being
put together get these keywords oh it
overheats or throttles it's a little
slow oh the hard drive at 256 gigabyte
version of the base model it's not fast
but do they understand the context and a
lot of people don't I've asked a lot of
friends I've asked people that aren't
even Tech heads and they were like is
the MacBook Air even worth getting
because I'm hearing a lot of complaints
about I'm like what complaints I've been
using over the past few weeks it's
awesome for what I'm using it for and
stick around to the end of this video
where I'll show you the configuration I
would go for for the MacBook Air if I'm
just using it as a daily machine without
photo and video editing now in my studio
I'm powered up with a MacBook Pro
16-inch M1 Max almost maxed out needs a
little bit more RAM but almost there
I've got an ISO 27 inch monitor that I'm
borrowing to test out here I'm recording
this on a red Komodo from a friend of
mine Peter Choi 6K I'm going to be
processing that in Final Cut audio is
going into Adobe Audition for my zoom F6
I've got a lot of things I'm doing in
this video that's being powered by this
MacBook Pro I'm not going to do that
with this MacBook Air why it probably is
not going to handle it okay especially
red footage it's not going to handle it
now it doesn't have a fan it will
throttle it will slow down when you're
pushing into that that extreme but if
I'm just going to be browsing the web
answering emails watching videos on
YouTube Netflix Disney Plus
I don't need any of that this is more
than adequate and that's why I want to
talk to you guys today about look if
you're looking for a basic laptop and
you want to get an Apple laptop because
they're pretty they're great they're
well made the software is fantastic they
sync up to your iPhone into your iPad I
get it this is a really nice machine the
updates to this air are fantastic the
better display the better webcam on this
now you've got more ports because you
have a MAG safe attachment to it so you
can charge by it that way it's sleeker
it's lighter it's thinner I mean I kind
of I'm nostalgic I like the original
design a little bit because that angular
design but when Steve Jobs pulled it out
of the envelope that was awesome but I
get it we have to evolve and this is not
too bad I got the Starlight version here
we're pretty much maxed out on our
review set and I would opt for a lighter
color because the darker color show
fingerprints this doesn't show it so
much but it's champagne gold so to each
their own but overall I like this
machine for what it is if I'm sitting
around the house I just want to chill
out and just browse the web and do some
shopping this is the laptop I'm going
for I'm not gonna go for my 16. I can do
it on the 16 but that's for work that's
for Pro work this is for my daily usage
I'm going to be traveling going on a
train I'm going to go to visit some
family or some friends I'm going on a
work trip or I need to do Zoom calls or
team calls this is the machine I will
opt for because it's easy it makes sense
and it handles everything I need to do
in that world very very well battery
life is good pretty much all day I
depends on my usage of course I push the
brightness up on my displays more than
others but you will lose a little bit of
battery on that regard but overall this
has been a very good machine I wish
there were more ports but the thing I
could say that about every Apple laptop
I wish there were more ports but that's
just me having said that though we got
to talk about this machine for a second
here because does this machine mean the
end of the 13 inch pro line I mean if
you look at it it kind of makes sense
right the proca start at the 14 and
there's one right now and it's fantastic
Pro 14 16 13 could be your MacBook Air
the laptop that you just need for your
daily tasks but the pro version that
could be for the 14 and 16 because Pros
usually need a larger display you you
know what I'm saying so something to
consider I don't know I'd love to hear
your thoughts on that but if you're
looking for the best configuration for
the MacBook Air as I mentioned earlier
let me talk to you about which I would
choose now there's two versions in terms
of the processor you can do 10 core or
eight core honestly speaking if you're
just doing medial tasks eight core is
more than adequate you probably won't
see much of a difference using the 10
core now in terms of unified Ram this is
where it gets tricky out of the box it's
eight gigabytes eight gigabytes will be
okay but 16 gigabytes is more future
proof if you're going to keep your
laptop for a few years I would offer 16
gigabytes now in terms of storage on
this this is where it's really tricky
256 gigabytes is not a lot of storage if
you're going to go into photos or video
that will fill up really really quickly
if you are not going to go into photos
and videos then stick with 256 you're
never going to see the performance
Improvement if you're just doing
documents and saving documents or you're
just watching movies and media content
you're never going to see it but if you
are going to get into photos and videos
then I would opt to go to 512 at least
let me get into the power bricks because
there's very different Power bricks that
you can get into you've got the Dual
USBC Port 35 watt version of it get the
67 watt Setter et cetera Etc the one out
of the box is pretty good but if you
want fast charging I would opt for the
67 watt I would forego the Dual USBC
Port version why for this reason most of
us plug our power bricks into a wall or
down by the floor and we're usually
sitting on a desk that means there's
quite a bit of distance between your
plug and where your laptop sits if I'm
going to plug in other USBC devices into
there I have to now get a longer cable
those are pretty expensive from Apple of
course you can go third party but if you
want to buy cable that's another expense
and then again are you going to be able
to reach is it going to work with your
desk situation that's only something
that you can answer personally for me I
wouldn't do it because I would never use
those ports I would take that 67 watt
charger which I think 67 is really a
good number to have because you can
charge many devices with that I can do
my iPhone iPad MacBook Air and whatever
device I need and you can get fast
charging it's great for when you're
traveling you are going to be golden and
it's not that big compared to the larger
versions out there anyway those are the
options I would go for I would love to
hear from you which MacBook Air version
would you like to go for let me know in
the comment section below if you like
this video check out these awesome
reviews from us right here